so I did a collab right mazod reps this
guy named Nick he's a chef Nick just
said Giovanni just a dude name there's a
guy named a random guy she saw him on
the street what's your name he's like
Nick cool you want it you want an agent
yeah all right for sure do you want to
hang out with my guy Nick I'd love to
collab he's just a dude yeah I like
chilling
here here was Nick
like so we shoot this Tick Tock together
right oh by the way Nick has a salt
company that I invested in it's like a
flavored salts and uh and so I was like
do you want to do a video with him a
tick tock and I was like yeah I'd love
to I I watch him on Tick Tock I really
like his stuff he's a really good Chef
he's like the youngest person ever to
win Iron Chef or whatever got it so he's
like yeah come over to my place and
we'll make uh we made like a Chick-fil-A
waffle sandwich right I don't know what
it's like to film you know how cooking
tick tocks are like the fastest tick
tocks yeah like each scene is like
literally half a second filming one of
those was absurd yeah it turns on his
camera he presses record and he goes and
just like does one thing and then it's
over and then he's like yeah I'm gonna
edit it to be even faster than that so I
said in the whole Tick Tock I said like
two words here we have our buns and here
we have my buns the whole time right and
uh he posts it on YouTube and this is
one of those I find Cody KO to be
absolutely cringe I'm sorry Nick but
you're too good for him this collab was
a cringe circus disaster
cringe circus man nice that's a good one
I just
I didn't yeah oh cringe
spoke how could you even cringe at like
a cooking video because he's a this he's
like a cooking Tick Tock connoisseur
there should be no words yeah no
dialogue yeah nothing yet at all no
speech yeah yeah and you spoke yeah he's
a purist we just want to hear the sound
of the food cooking sizzling no talking
to me this was the same Vibe as the like
you ruined my Saturday yeah this is a 15
second video and he watched it he was
like dude this was a cringe circus two
clowns so funny to think about your face
just existing in the frame and he's just
like oh God God my whole body this is a
disaster
this is the better one though so I did a
video with me Canyon another one he sent
me a screenshot of this and was like uh
bro what were you thinking having me
back on because this kid tweets at meat
Canyon is so annoying in Cody's videos
he just adds 10 extra minutes of
meaningless conversation and copying
what Cody already said so then meat
Canyon responded to it and was like Hey
like thanks for the
I don't know what he said but it's
something like cheeky and funny yeah and
the kid goes uh Lamar what is happening
right now and of course I still watch
Meet Canon if it makes you feel better
you're still so much better this is this
is another guy right and then this is
the same guy Thomas that says this dude
no way you actually replied I'm a huge
fan of Cody I'm sorry for being negative
I never thought you would actually see
that and then Charlie goes well now shut
up Thomas it's too late yeah you're a
[ __ ] Thomas like straight up you're a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you spoke that with your
chest and then the Dude shows up and
you're like oh
oh man I'm
I take it back that was mean you're a
punk man isn't that absurd yeah it's
just you know whatever dude sorry for
being negative bro [ __ ]
if you're gonna be negative Only We own
it don't be negative and just dude I was
kidding don't be negative online then I
just love this dude shut up Thomas it's
too late yeah your friend knows what's
up yeah like your boy see that's a good
friend he's kicking you while you're
down because that's what you need dude
no I thought I was kidding yo shut the
[ __ ] up bro you [ __ ] it you're an
idiot
you're a [ __ ]
you're a dumbass
it's too late it's too late Thomas go to
bed Thomas it's too late all right let
me tuck you in yeah because it's too
late way past your bedtime buddy it's
too late oh what time is it uh too late
buddy yeah sorry no but I just I
would say I'm too late nah nah but guys
I'm sorry I I just I I love I meet
Canyon and I nah it's too late
if you're gonna take it back go back
with some nuts you know I'm sorry for
being negative I still hate me Ken yeah
yeah no like you just say hey my bad
that was [ __ ] up you're still [ __ ]
annoying though yeah okay yeah you know
stay on your ground like be negative if
you're gonna be negative oh I didn't
think you'd respond that's what it took
oh you groupie
that's like standing for a whole there's
a whole problem with the internet right
there yeah right there yeah you're gonna
be negative just do it that's like
standard Front Road a concert and just
like eye rolling the whole set and then
the artist goes like yo man appreciate
your support and you're like no
oh
I was kidding I know this song and you
start bouncing it's like no no you don't
get to be you know an [ __ ] for the
first 20 minutes of the set and then
when I finally do industry baby now you
want to wrap along with me get the [ __ ]
out of here I'm just kidding Thomas just
giving you a hard time you wouldn't know
though because it's too late it's too
late you should be asleep right now sit
next to be hearing any of this
commentary
foreign